♪ ♪
>> Laura: A LITTLE OVER TEN
WEEKS AGO, MASS RIOTING AND
LOOTING BROKE OUT IN THE WAKE OF
GEORGE FLOYD’S DEATH.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN DAMAGE WAS DONE.
LIVES AND 1500 BUSINESSES WERE
DESTROYED.
I SPOKE WITH SOME OF THOSE
BUSINESS OWNERS RIGHT HERE IN
MINNEAPOLIS.
>> THIS IS WHERE IT ALL
HAPPENED.
MAY 27TH, 2 DAYS AFTER THE
KILLING OF GEORGE FLOYD, THE
AUTOZONE WHICH IS RIGHT HERE
BURNED TO THE GROUND.
THEN IT WAS TARGET.
TERRIBLY DAMAGED, DESTROYED,
LOOTED.
IMPORTANT FOR THE COMMUNITY,
MINNESOTA COMPANY OF COURSE.
AND THEN THE PRECINCT ABANDONED
NOW, BUT DESTROYED, BURNED, AND
THEY ALLOWED IT TO BURN.
MORE THAN TEN WEEKS LATER, WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN THIS COMMUNITY?
WHAT ABOUT THESE BUSINESSES THAT
WANT TO REBUILD, THAT WANT TO
STAY HERE.
ONE OF THE ROAD BLOCKS, WHAT ARE
THE PROBLEMS, AND HOW CAN WE
MOVE FORWARD?
WE DECIDED TO COME HERE AND TRY
TO BRING YOU THESE STORIES AND I
HOPE SHED LIGHT ON WHAT HAPPENS
TOHAS TO HAPPEN NEXT.
>> HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY BURNING
DOWN SOMEONE’S BUSINESS?
>> Laura: CASEY WHITE AND HER
HUSBAND CHARLES STARTED AN
INCREDIBLE BUSINESS MY BUSINESS
FOR YOUR YEARS AGO.
>> I WATCHED THE OLD SIDE COME
BURNING TO THE GROUND.
MY HUSBAND WAS ASLEEP AND I SAID
"YOU NEED TO WAKE UP NOW!"
AND WE SAT THERE AND WATCHED IT
JUST MELT TO THE GROUND.
ALL OF OUR HARD WORK.
>> PEOPLE WITH BATS, PEOPLE AT
THE FRONT WINDOWS, HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE WENT IN AND LOOTED.
THEN THEY CAME BACK THE NEXT
NIGHT, AND THE NEXT NIGHT.
SIX SHIRES, IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
JOHN WOLF IS A PROMINENT
MINNEAPOLIS BUSINESS DEALER.
>> Laura: THIS IS THE FAMOUS
DOOR OF HER EVERYBODY WAS COMING
IN AND OUT DURING THE NIGHTS OF
THE RIOTS AND THE LOOTING.
THEY TOOK AS MUCH AS THEY COULD
OUT OF THAT DOOR.
>> THEY WERE COMING IN FROM THE
BASEMENT, THEY WERE COMING OUT
HERE, THEY WERE TAKING SHOPPING
CARTS.
>> Laura: HOW MUCH MERCHANDISE
WAS TAKEN OUT?
>> A MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
MERCHANDISE.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THAN THAT, IT’S
NOW TAKEN 40 PLUS JOBS AWAY FROM
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
WHO LIVED, SHOPPED, AND WORK
HERE.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE GUYS?
>> Laura: 30 YEARS AGO, HE
CAME HERE WITH HIS FAMILY FROM
ETHIOPIA FOR A BETTER LIFE.
THIS IS WHAT’S LEFT OF IT.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS THOUGH MIKE
HAPPENED TEN WEEKS AGO AT THE
MINNEAPOLIS RIOTS.
>> WE PUT OUR SWEAT INTO THIS
BUILDING.
>> Laura: I HEARD THE CITY HAD
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH YOU ABOUT ONE
ISSUE INVOLVING...
>> THE CITY CAME IN AND PUT UP
WITH THE FUNDS AS YOU SEE HERE.
AND THEY SENT OUT THE BILL FOR
$3700.
THEY SAID THEY DON’T HAVE ANY
RESOURCES.
SO THE CITY THAT YOU SUPPORT,
THE BIG COMMUNITIES, SEND YOU A
BILL?
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
LET’S REBUILD THIS COMMUNITY AND
TO STAND BY IT.
WE LET OUR COUNTRY FOR A FUTURE
TO SEE THE AMERICAN DREAM.
AND LOOK HOW IT HAPPENED.
WE HAVE NOT DONE ANYTHING WRONG.
THE PEACEFUL PROTEST WAS
HIJACKED, THEN THE GOVERNMENT
CAN -- WHERE ARE THEY?
IT’S BEEN TEN WEEKS.
NO RESPONSE.
>> Laura: NO RESPONSE.
SILENCE WAS AS DEAFENING ON THE
NIGHT ON THE RIOTS.
THE SILENCE FROM ELECTED
OFFICIALS IS STILL DEAFENING.
LARRY McKENZIE, LONGTIME
HIGH SCHOOL BASKETBALL COACH,
YOUTH ADVOCATES, AND NORTH
MINNEAPOLIS.
SO MANY PEOPLE LOVE YOU, LARRY.
IT WAS SHE COULD BE IN THE
STUDIO WITH ME HERE.
WHAT IS IT GOING TO TAKE TO
TRULY GET MINNEAPOLIS BACK ON
ITS FEET?
THESE ARE GREAT PEOPLE.
I GOT A CHANCE TO MEET SO MANY
WONDERFUL PEOPLE TODAY.
THESE ARE GOOD NEIGHBORS, GOOD
PEOPLE, BUT THEY ARE MAD.
AND THEY ARE HEARTBROKEN, BUT
THEY ARE MAD.
>> I MEAN, RIGHTFULLY SO.
IN TERMS OF WHAT IT’S GOING TO
TAKE, ONE OF THE THINGS IS A
TIME AROUND ELECTIONS AND
POLITICIANS MAKING PROMISES AND
THOSE KIND OF THINGS.
IT’S GOING TO TAKE REALLY THE
COMMUNITY HOLDING THOSE WHO ARE
IN THOSE POSITIONS ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Laura: ASKED A NUMBER OF
THE FOLKS I INTERVIEWED WHERE
THE POLITICIANS ARE?
THEY HAPPEN TO BE MOSTLY
DEMOCRATS.
THEY SAID NO ONE IS HERE.
WE NEVER HEAR FROM THEM.
WE CALL THEM, THEY OFFER
SYMPATHY, BUT THEY SAY WE HAVE
TO HAVE A CHANGE.
AND THE NEW PEOPLE COME IN AND
THEY ARE NO GOOD, WE WILL KICK
THEM OUT TOO.
THAT WAS BASICALLY THE
SENTIMENT.
THEY WANT POLITICAL CHANGE.
>> I DON’T THINK YOU CAN -- I
DON’T THINK I WOULD DISAGREE.
I THINK OBVIOUSLY FROM WHAT I
HAVE SEEN THAT RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
LEADERSHIP THAT IS NOT IN TOUCH
WITH THE COMMUNITY, THAT IS NOT
NECESSARILY REPRESENTING THE
VOICE OF THE COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: I’M GOING TO BRING
YOU BACK TOMORROW NIGHT, BECAUSE
WE WILL BE HERE TOMORROW NIGHT.